you
okay this is an hourly bulla arena 45
are entered in it appears I'm going to
get paired up wit spot pie around 1:00
okay I'm feeling a little bit more
confident with my mouse okay I think
that was an opportunity to play d5 let's
pin their night let's take am I not
winning a piece now my queen takes I
would have had that all right I'm in a
good spot you're in a good spot let's
get here it's juicy
oh yeah
Oh Queen has to go to f1 Queen f1 what's
that what's the scoop with that let's
get out of this pin up a piece let's
kick that bishop away I'm gonna end up
in a pin let's secure that night we're
doing all right on the clock just hang
on to that pond and let's get this rook
working maybe King f8 just to be a
little bit on the safe side Queen takes
here and I could still do that time
advantage okay we have a lot of material
now bishops having a tough day and we're
crashing through on f2 where is the mate
there it is on my favorite square my
favorite square H to Bill Gates where
are you all right 23 minutes 40 seconds
trackpad I was right you play Knight f3
I really have to shake that shake that
move off with these bullet games Larry
we're gonna we're gonna except it's
another problem let's go here and I'll
hide my king on this square take what
the pawn hit the night and then I could
defend it for hmm that's a piece they
resigned back to tournament that was a
quick one 5 for 4 for 23 minutes 59
players are now in that guy that's in
first he's uh he withdrew that might
have been an accident though okay let's
build in the center okay they wasted a
little bit of time there all right now I
could open up this h-file maybe get a
little bit more development in huh pawn
push all right play against their
structure I guess uh okay let's get this
here I want to get rid of their glue
who's the glue they're bishop actually
their knight is very good on that square
I'm floundering
provoke okay they didn't react to that
now I could definitely undermine their
bishop it's their knight who I have to
next worry about so we're going to get
rid of their night and then I get some
good play finally with my rooks against
their pawns or a very weakened very weak
bonds let's grab him give it check get
my rooks working and sneak my king up
and that's bush and just keep pushing
here actually this should be pretty
clean and let's go here and slowly keep
advancing that was a very silly move
what I did there it's all right though
too many fast pawns
no stalemates push no stalemates and
that's me back to tournament eight eight
five four trackpad again I'm going to
decline this gambit just a psycho to say
that I'm ready to just take on c6 all
right this is a nothing advantage here
for white unless maybe they give me the
H file let's see in here I think they
have to play Bishop h5 otherwise night
here and then get try to get it there
Bishop hmm in there Knight Bishop g6
okay I spent a lot of time there
there Knights still pinned I don't want
to be too quick to give this guy up
I guess play with a four bishop on h4 is
hanging I don't know I pass I don't know
what to do when in doubt throw your King
in the corner it's got to be good all
right let's go opposite their queen
maybe f5 my knight on D to off-site
offsets the knight right there okay
let's break maybe with the pollen
actually they're really asking for
trouble I don't see a good discovery
though I still have it in mind let's
come over here
I wanted f7 they resigned although they
were down on time as well twelve twelve
eight-six
less than 19 already I don't still go
for efore this is the mouse loop the
mouse slipped efore well that's a pond
let's drop back waste a little time but
I am up the pond
alright they weaken their light squares
near their king
can I take advantage of this now hold
off I'm playing h3 they would probably
sack strike at their center and maybe
even do something very caveman like line
up a battery against their king that
paralyzes their f6 Knight all right some
Queen trade play against c7 interesting
winning this pond though they can't
defend that the ref pond can't move so
this pond Falls night 85 I could first
give him a kick and then capture here so
I'm gonna take with the Queen because I
would welcome a queen exchange now that
I'm up material fish should be seven I
guess here they might challenge my night
soon with that five night in to see four
let's keep pushing I have six code
recovered now and a tsunami of ponds
let's stop any f5 break on each five I
go h3 prove my king physician and you
can just slowly expand here on the Queen
side I want to keep control over f5
let's keep going here and let's break
open up the D file and now these guys
are pushing through they're down on time
back to term it's sixteen twelve twelve
twelve okay all right let's try a
Sicilian okay let's form a pawn duo they
waste a little bit of time there hmm
I think I have to pin
otherwise they I dropped that pond let's
defend d5 so they wasted if I'm not
mistaken they played d3 and then d4 and
so they wasted a little bit of time
there let's get out of the pin take with
the night I have to defend here let's
reinforce of d5 mmm let's do this first
okay this is a little bit sensitive
actually and it's pointed f2 let's come
over here let me get their light square
Bishop 95 the bishop pair but their
Knights the Knights are pretty strong
I have h3 covered huh I don't know here
oh I'm threatening mate huh only
realizing that now Queen here's a mate
threat
I'll watch out now still maybe you mates
right if the knight moves let's get some
trades in I'm dropping a pond at the end
I have a slight time edge is it enough
though that it be a pre move machine oh
you can't
without your pinned man who the old-time
burner race ah man less than 15 call it
14 minutes left 2016 14 14 I don't hold
my breath it's just I'm really I'm
speechless I just I was just I'm
reciting myself just move all you need
to do is keep moving keep moving or you
will lose on time keep on moving why
don't you two put your knight in there
with tempo why don't you do that I want
to keep that night at kick before I play
here otherwise the knight gets to make
use of this square there we go no we're
gonna come in this direction my knight
is a juicy piece actually we're gonna
get smothered mate I was playing a
little hope just there they saw it they
saw and now I gave up my support of this
this night I was looking for some hope
just their Bishop takes Knight oh no I
didn't want to Pat ah let's get rid of
their night that's what I get for
playing hope chess
let's open up this I guess take here oh
I didn't recapture what the other night
I get the dark squares though no Bishop
here I get a sack
yepper no that rookie think he wants to
go somewhere else he doesn't they have
control over that diagonal as well as
here I'm hitting a g2 but it's poison
um come here I'm getting that pond
though it was helpful I think they
should have played there I got this time
edge you interrupt the exchange classic
time burner time burner back determine
24 23 21 18 less than 12 I had to start
playing better that was yeah that was so
clear Hope Chest there when I took and
released my control over my on my night
there in the center in the latest video
- I'm talking about not playing hope
chess look what I just did oh man I
already know what the EU 5 I'm gonna
throw a night in here soon
get out of there all right and I play
with the bishop pair all right it's very
awkward now for them to defend well
let's go over here I think it's pretty
clear now I just scoop of that beep on
OK 7 isn't a defense and because of what
ok so that's what they're up to I think
I want to trade what do I want to do ok
their night is having a tough day be a
mouse race
yep alrighty and try something sneaky
that's the sneaky stuff I was talking
about and how are we doing on the clock
sneaky sneak artist alright this is
gonna be tricky dunk I made it
hmm that night is such a dangerous piece
man he's so dangerous if I thought that
he was gonna somehow weave a mate all on
his own he is that dangerous unless nine
minutes left 28 27 22 man you should put
the fear in every chess player if a
knight does not scare you yet
just haven't played enough chess all
right
they just secured their Bishop we're
gonna throw a rook on the C file and
then go after their King yeah all right
oh let's pin their night they can't feel
too comfortable there oh all right let's
focus on c4 I'm also striking here
Nightbeat Knight g3 was pretty serious
hmm all right let's open up the H file
maybe there's some tension
going on with this that night out of
there
it's a Johnny Pest he takes pawn look at
my time okay now I think we're we're
cruising somehow or somehow cruising
that night is hit mm-hmm defend it's
tough for me to assess this position
okay I have everything defended that
pawn rolling cover some squares I think
it's going to drop in there don't get
made it on g7 I need extra protection
here
hmm
seven seconds Oh sneaky speechless 32:27
26:24 man less than seven alrighty
hmm all right would you just make a move
man and they're right they don't have
any development no development maybe I
could try to take advantage of that Hana
All Right Hon push I could take the
bishop in-betweener
in the in-betweener
now how are their dark squares looking
let's stop there Bishop from coming to
life now that I'm weakened on these
light squares near my King side alright
Bishop d3 here we go strong piece let's
break let's open up this F file um okay
now we're gonna do this and just open up
the e-file there Kings still in the
middle this pawn is going to be a thorn
can't Castle now doing this to keep the
Queen's on the board I want to drop a
knight in here no trades
than sneaky here I'm not sure what that
was about
I'm not sure that what that was about
right there
okay we got a clock advantage I was
gonna get rolling rec activity let's
keep it really simple and just keep
going here they're down on time man
36 34 28 27 I play against this guy yet
backward okay and he's still within
striking distance he's on fire is he
playing right now no I guess we're gonna
get paired up this is a big one ooh
gotta get this oh no oh no uh-oh having
a flashbacks of being berserk and
getting smashed okay I like my position
age too yeah how did I know that that
would be defended how did I know all
right
yikes mm-hmm he takes pawn hmm all right
can I win on time
that's an odd move that's a little bit
odd oh they're gonna take here no 21
still okay I don't have a good feeling
about this game
yikes oh yeah let's just resign back to
tournament 39-36 30-27 less than three
left in this one and they withdrew and
this is a new account - 450 - whoa
berserk in everybody craziness all right
let's go see five
let's take they withdraw or did they get
booted from the tournament all right
let's go here and grab that pawn off for
a queen exchange check I need to get
this one more game in mm-hmm it's Castle
kingside
get on this diagonal they they weaken
their queen size squares dark squares
pinpoint c3 uh I don't want to castle
anymore secure my rook rook c7 stop
Knight B 5 H 6 is an idea now pinpoint
f4 work on both wings now 4 is
collapsing the knight has to retreat hit
this guy mmm
taken then pin the night threatening
both of these pawns now with the pin the
pin against the night let's just take
him out take here secure my king
physician let's get here take with the
bishop and then hunt this guy down next
I'm in a pin try to get out of that as
soon as possible let's go here Bishop
here I'm out of the pin good
coordination next phase is hunt down
this pond and they're being sneaky there
this will make it a lot easier now
simplified and keep the pawns on light
squares and then mate back to tournament
39 38 I'm down a point and that's gonna
do it I'm not gonna get another game in
39 38 34 30
84 players whoo that's a good turnout
all right let me see oh wait a second
how did I get first wonder what happened
there I could I thought I lost the game
I guess I'm mistaken I guess I didn't
lose huh it's just my imagination
ah somebody was being another sneak
artist shame on you man shame on you
forty thirty eight thirty twenty seven
twenty six twenty six twenty three
twenty three twenty two twenty all right
let's see it else took part in this page
two three four five six
seven eight alright alright
to the 84 of you who played honestly you
are awesome
a games all